bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
pour ce débat de la matinale alors on va
commencer par le pouvoir d'achat des
français hier jean castex a donc annoncé
un coup de pouce supplémentaire pour
faire face à la hausse des prix des
carburants et donc après le chèque
carburant il a eu ce relèvement de 10 %
du barème de l'indemnité kilométrique
regardez
j'ai donc demandé au ministre de
l'économie et des finances de modifier
dès cette semaine l'arrêté définissant
le barème kilométrique il sera réhaussé
de 10% afin de mieux tenir compte de la
hausse réelle des prix supportés par ces
ménages l'effet sera rapide et directe
effet rapide et directe mais qui va pas
concerner tout le monde votre réaction
pierre cabaret sur cette mesure
bien les fêlés ne va pas concerner tout
le monde effectivement puisque 10% des
personnes sont son tarot réel
pour l'instant c'est ainsi chaque mesure
peut s'améliorer ou peut éventuellement
évoluer vers un système un peu plus
qui concernera plus un plus grand nombre
de français un peu plus près et pérenne
pris des mesures à la va-vite et un
manque d'anticipation ça fait pas c'est
pas d'hier que les prix augmentent
c'est pas dire qu'elle est prêts
augmente mais augmenté dans ces
proportions là c'est vrai que c'est
important et c'est important de pouvoir
avoir une réponse pérenne donc c'est
aussi important de se laisser quelques
quelques jours pour améliorer cette
situation alors blanc quelle est votre
réaction à cette mesure
décidé hier en urgence par jean castex
effectivement moi j'ai été un peu
surprise de cette décision du
gouvernement parce que c'est une
proposition que par le valérie pécresse
depuis plusieurs mois cette augmentation
du barème kilométrique
donc c'est vrai que c'est une
proposition que la candidate valérie
pécresse a fait donc les fortes heureux
qu'il ait reprise simplement on voit
bien qu encore les mesures sont
parcellaires et quand même le
gouvernement aujourd'hui dénoncent
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence mais
c'est quand même le gouvernement qui
augmenterait aussi les taxes sur
l'essence et on voit bien aujourd'hui
elles sont très importantes
le gouvernement ne semble pas absolument
pas prendre en compte cette augmentation
est encore la semaine dernière j'ai
discuté avec une collègue de 2005
apparaît enfin qui est comme si une
collègue à l'assemblée nationale qui le
disaient que pour endiguer cette
augmentation du prix de l'essence
notamment en zone rurale n'y avait pas
de problème mais toute manière on avait
des transports en commun il y en avait
des véhicules électriques donc ça
c'était l'avenir qui sont peu la réalité
du terrain elle est toute autre c'est ce
qu'elle accepte on a besoin de notre
véhicule pour aller travailler se
déplacer pour pouvoir vivre tout
simplement
content c'est une revendication qui
datent de longueur des français et
notamment le monde et chez les jaunes
donc bien sûr qu'il faut prendre à bras
le corps cette question alors ça
effectivement ce qu'avait aussi à manuel
macro hier quelques étés en haute-vienne
qu' il fallait aller vers des idées des
véhicules moins polluants qui
consommerait moins d'énergie donc ça
résoudrait la situation n'est pas pas
sur le court terme pierre cabaret est-ce
que le gouvernement va annoncer d'autres
mesures
alors bien sûr d'abord je laisse les
paroles de mes collègues députés et il
leur appartient il est évident que les
transports en commun en plus depuis
depuis des décennies ali n'ont pas été
là ils n'ont pas évolué en tout cas de
la façon dont on aurait pu les voir
évoluer et surtout à aujourd'hui on a
une difficulté et une grande difficulté
avec ses transports en commun donc le
temps qu'ils évoluent effectivement
l'essence sera sûrement à 2 euros mais
cette cet état de fait ne n'est pas de
notre ressort aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que les taxes n'ont pas été baptisé
aujourd'hui n'ont pas été rehaussé
aujourd'hui entendre madame blain en
plus impatients que les taxes et nous
qui l'avons inventé n'ont donc cet axe
là m6 le ressort est important est-ce
qu'on peut les baisser les taxes mais
attache à la
à la marge sa frappe très peu de choses
il faut absolument
initiés autre chose et quand on voit les
sens augmenter cette façon là et
j'entends bien que les personnes et moi
on a tous besoin de notre voiture donc
et surtout en milieu rural d'ailleurs
donc il est évident qu'il faut trouver
il faut améliorer et c'est cet aspect là
que le monsieur castex envisage de faire
c'est un début ce n'est pas une fin
voilà et je suis ravi que finalement
nous fassions une chose que madame
preuve pécresse a proposé puisque
et bien là on est à la manoeuvre et on
fait donc c'est pour dire que finalement
il ya des choses intéressantes
nord blanc c'est votre sentiment ou est
ce que c'est on va piquer les idées des
candidats
il ya vraiment pas de mots moi je pense
qu'il vaut mieux préférer l'original à
la copie et l'original c'est valérie
pécresse sa copie c'est le gouvernement
voilà ça vient d'être dit ils ont
attendu ils ont attendu on est en fin de
quinquennat ils ont besoin de donner des
gages à la population l'on voit bien que
ce n'est pas un mouvement de fond un
mouvement de réformes telles que le
demande valérie pécresse d'eau à
comprendre les simples idées nasa n'a
pas d'intérêt en revanche accompagner
les idées du de la candidate pécresse de
réforme parce qu'elles sont
indispensables parce que là on parle des
frais kilométriques de l'augmentation
des prix d'essence mais faut pas oublier
que les particuliers sont affectés mais
les autres reprise aussi et lorsque
j'entends évoqué la question des
transports en commun il y a énormément
de choses et paul a aussi porté valérie
pécresse sur la bureaucratisation
impressionnante aujourd'hui que vino
pays et nous entreprises notamment en
matière de transports en commun le
ministère de l'intérieur par exemple
interdit aux chauffeurs d'autocars donc
qui permettrait le chip de ma vie
territorialement notre territoire deux
campagnes de pouvoir rpt côté des
chauffeurs autocaristes pour accompagner
justement ces moyens de communication
dans les campagnes on voit bien que
cette réforme enfin en flic à cette
proposition des frais kilométriques est
reprise totalement jean candidat mais
n'est pas accompagnée d'un mouvement de
fond tel qu'il est nécessaire de le
mettre en place et encore une fois je
crois qu'il vaut mieux préférer
l'original valérie pécresse est une pâle
copie quel gouvernement joue alors à la
une de l'actualité également il ya cette
enquête choc sur la maltraitance en
ehpad un problème qui revient
régulièrement dans l'actualité c'est le
groupe hors pair qui est qui est mise en
cause le ministre de la santé a été
interpellé hier à l'assemblée à ce sujet
regardez
le ferez preuve et avec de gilles
bourguignon dudit vivront croyez moi à
la plus grande sévérité si le serait ce
qu'un pourcentage des faits qui sont
alléguées dans le livre devait s'avérer
vrai et nous donnerons tous les moyens
pour vérifier la réalité de ces faits
alors au delà d'ouvrir une enquête que
doit faire le gouvernement pour faire
cesser cette logique de rentabilité au
mépris de toute humanité envers nos
aînés le patron d'ailleurs du groupe
orpea et est convoqué par par l'exécutif
pierre cabaret que doit faire le
gouvernement
personnes âgées c'est un sujet qui n'a
absolument pas été traité par le
gouvernement depuis le début ils vont
tous sur cette question et aujourd'hui
et vous à venir il ya des buts il est le
plan jamais eu et donc il n'y a
tellement eu aucun débat aucun sujet
aucune club passion de cette thématique
très important pour l'accompagnement de
nos aînés à titre personnel je fais lui
depuis 2020 et ma première opposition
doit à aider des compagnies nous n' y
est mieux dans leur frenchie on doit
leur permettre notamment le maintien à
domicile ou à leur permettre d'avoir des
personnes à leur coûter d'avoir des
accompagnants qui puisse être valorisés
et puisse leur permet d'avoir une fin de
vie sereine et donc effectivement la
complication ce livre a le mérite de
remettre le sujet sur la table et c'est
un vrai sujet de préoccupation dans les
territoires dont on nous parle tous les
jours donc découvrir aujourd'hui et
enfin de ministre de la santé nous
expliquer que si ça te verrai vrai il
faudrait faire des choses mais il n'a
rien n'était fait pendant cinq ans
aidera match il m'a quand même sous
nicolas sarkozy la loi grand âge n'a
jamais été débattue c'est pourtant c'est
pourtant un sujet qui avait été évoqué
par par nicolas sarkozy également par
parra par emmanuel macron mais cette
fois grand âge pour l'instant on
toujours pas levé la loi de grand âge
évoquée par nicolas sarkozy ça fait dix
ans qu'on est plus au pouvoir je tiens
simplement à préciser il ya quand même
eu un mandat de cinq ans de françois
hollande avec emmanuel macron au sein du
gouvernement emmanuel macron à la
présidence de la république donc durant
ces dix ans il ne s'est absolument rien
passé sur la question du grand âge et
aux grands voiliers ça à l'opposition
alors que nous ne sommes plus au pouvoir
depuis un petit moment c'est un petit
peu facile en revanche la ce que je vous
dis c'est que sur cette question pendant
cinq ans nous ne sommes jamais préoccupé
de l'avenir de nos personnes âgées et
des conditions de vie de nos personnes
âgées alors qu'il est évoqué en revanche
des questions telles que l'euthanasie
par exemple eh ben moi je trouve ça
particulièrement choquant parce que
quand on préfère se préoccuper
d'euthanasie et non d'accompagnement
dans des conditions de vie décentes de
nos aînés sa pelouse de vrais sujets de
société alors on a perdu pierre cabaret
malheureusement énorme là on va
continuer avec vous sur ces questions
d'actualité vous parliez d'améliorer le
travail d'aidé soignant dans les ehpad
notamment or on le voit c'est vers une
logique une logique d'argent qui prévaut
et qui fait qu'il ya des maltraitances
ce sont des groupes privés quels moyens
d'action concrètement les le
gouvernement pourrait-il avoir
tout simplement il faut que le
gouvernement que l'état que la force
publique la puissance publique m
sincèrement suffisamment d'argent pour
qu'on accompagne nos aînés on voit que
nos aînés ville ni heures s'ils sont
accompagnés si le personnel qui est à
leurs côtés étant suffisamment grand
nombre aujourd'hui n'a clairement pas
assez du personnel il viendrait pas à
l'idée de poser public contre privé là
n'est pas le l'enjeu de la question mais
c'est simplement de donner des moyens
que l'on puisse avoir du personnel
autour de nos personnes âgées et le
ségur comme des souvent évoquée a laissé
bon nombre de personnes sur le côté il
ne traite absolument pas tout les sujets
toutes les préoccupations
des personnels de santé des personnels
dans les établissements qui s'occupe des
personnes âgées on voit bien qu'il ya eu
sur le côté encore une fois des gens qui
ont été exclus et qui n'ont pas eu de
revalorisation salariale or c'est aussi
important de valoriser les personnes qui
se donnent pour nos personnes âgées
parce que de cet accompagnement nous
verrons que les personnes âgées se sont
beaucoup mieux beaucoup plus entourées
et beaucoup moins isolés hausse demain
s'ouvre là la course aux parrainages
pour les candidats à la présidentielle
pas question de modifier la pratique de
ces parrainages public des maires avant
le vote cette année c'est ce qu'a
déclaré hier le président du conseil
constitutionnel regarder
il serait sans doute de bonnes
pratiques démocratiques que cette
question qui revient quand même peu à
chaque fois
ci elle doit être examinée et tranché le
soir
plutôt début de mandat au milieu mandat
que à la fin lorsqu'on on bute sur les
délais alors faut-il le faire à dès le
début du prochain mandat présidentiel
mais aurait-il fallu modifier cette
règle maintenant un an blanc la question
des parrainages et les simples elle est
de savoir aujourd'hui par rapport aux
élus par rapport aux gens qui sont
impliqués dans les territoires quel
candidat à la présidentielle il souhaite
porter pour qu'il y ait véritablement un
débat sur les sujets de société donc je
crois que la règle des parrainages elle
est effectivement aujourd'hui importante
parce que ça évite un certain temps de
candidature qui pourrait venir
s'imposer dans le débat sans même
véritablement de légitimité
d'imprégnation sur les territoires après
il ya effectivement au delà de la
question du nombre de parrainages la
question des publications des noms qui
peut poser problème pour un certains
d'entre eux mais je crois que les maires
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs dans l'ordre
dans une grande majorité ont
leur avis sur la question et
parraineront sans aucune difficulté des
candidats est la plus impressionnante
habilité et est parrainée en tout cas
les choix qui sont plutôt bien placés
dans les sondages a priori
par une roue à mon âge y est c'est en
tout cas le ressenti que nous avons à
l'égard de valérie pécresse une
candidate qui sera la plus à même de
créer de susciter l'alternance et de de
faire battre emmanuel macron parce qu'au
jour j'aimerais bien ça sur les
territoires et ça c'est très important
qu'on n'a pas de doute sur les
parrainages pour valérie pécresse ma
question c'est est évidemment plus tôt
pour pour eric zemmour dans là pour qui
la question se pose
mais eric zemmour marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon ils auront leur signature
parce qu'effectivement ils vont au
contact du territoire et donc ils ont
très probablement leur signature je
pense qu'il y aura pas de grande
surprise mais effectivement on voit qu à
chaque veille de présidentielle on
essaie de faire monter la pression faire
croire qu'on ne les aura pas mais très
sincèrement je pense que tous ces euros
c'est faire durer le suspense faire
cabaret sur cette question des
parrainages on a entendu leurs
entrailles du ciel le débat sur une
modification des règles pourraient se
tenir après l'élection mais pas avant ce
débat est nécessaire gens vous
d'après moi ce débat est nécessaire mais
il faut en informer les français
il faut informer les français sur les
conditions de financement de ces choses
là parce que 500 signatures ça donne
droit à un financement public or on ne
peut pas avoir n'importe quel champ task
qui se présente à une élection
présidentielle est touché de l'argent
public ça c'est une première chose
ensuite il faut arrêter de prendre les
français un peu pour des ânes je crois
que ce sont eux qui font les d'action ce
sont eux qui votent et ce sont eux qui
doivent être concernées et ce sont eux
qui donnent l'argent pour c'est pour ces
candidats là ensuite je excusez moi il
ya une coupure essaie de manger je
voulais juste te revenir sur une chose
la grande différence entre valérie
pécresse et notre président de la
république emmanuel macron c'est que il
y en a une qui est candidat et qu'il
peut raser gratis et on le voit très
souvent dans les campagnes et l'autre
qui est à la manoeuvre et pour cette
manoeuvre là effectivement il ay langage
et langages le gouvernement il engage
des français j'engage des financements
et ça c'est important aussi de le dire
et c'est pour ça qu'il est moins candide
en ce moment et c'est pour ça qu'il se
portera et je le souhaite candidats un
jour pour pouvoir contre qui vivait cet
engagement vis-à-vis des français cet
engagement financier cet engagement qui
nous a portés qui nous a fait traverser
cette crise et qui nous a portés vers le
meilleur voilà je crois qu'il faut
donner à la foi de l'espérance mais moi
je ne suis pas en campagne aujourd'hui
je suis pour continuer à gérer cette
france donc si valérie pécresse a décidé
de faire campagne ça la regarde mes vins
blancs de grâce ne nous dit pas que
demain on va raser gratis parce que ça
les français mais en ont mais ras-le-bol
et ça ça ne sera jamais de mon fait
jamais jamais jamais et jamais du fait
du président de la république jamais
jamais jamais voilà donc vous pouvez
continuer emmanuelle b 13 m certains la
meilleure des candidates pour vous et je
le conçois aisément parce que vous la
supporter mais le président emmanuel
chrome emmanuel macron et la personne
qui gère aujourd'hui la france qui la
gère bien et le gouvernement avec jean
castex je le soutiens et très largement
c'est normal c'est de bonne guerre une
réponse courte anne leblanc
écoutez je suis assez atterré de ce
genre de réponse parce que eh bien sûr
que la majorité parlementaire va
soutenir le président de la république
ils ont tout fait pendant cinq ans les
yeux fermés à suivre aveuglément les
propositions du gouvernement et du
président de la république simplement
quand on évoque le raser gratis ça fait
quand même plus de six mois que le
président de la république distribuer
des chèques à tout va pour acheter des
français le dernier en date étant le
flou dieu chèque de 100 euros qui de
clermont ne répond absolument pas aux
problématiques du terrain donc voilà je
pense que au moins l'honnêteté elle est
du côté de valérie pécresse oui elle est
candidate oui elle veut être présidente
de la république et elle le sera pas
encore une fois on voit bien que le
gouvernement navigue à vue et plus qu'il
ne sait pas quoi faire reprend les
programmes et les propositions de la
candidate pécresse donc encore une fois
les exercice d'autosatisfaction alors on
voit bien la situation dans laquelle se
trouvent deux pays sont clairement
inutile et enfin voter pour l'original
alors il reste peu de temps jour est
votre réaction sur sur ce sondage qui
est quand même assez surprenant les
français se positionne de plus en plus à
droite selon un sondage que vous voyez
apparaître à l'écran un sondage réalisé
par le cevipof 63% des sondés pensent
qu'il ya trop d'immigrés en france est
très surprenant 39 % seraient favorables
à une dictature pierre cabaret qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce sondage
eh bien je pense que les sondages les
français répondent à des sondages avec
une conception de la dictature qui est
certainement à la française et qui va
vite et en tout cas
je crois que le module le mot dictature
il faut le sortir son vocabulaire
c'était épouvantable une dictature était
rentable donc les français n'en voudrait
pas et ne voudrais surtout pas cette
dictature l'a ensuite moi j'étais
sérieuses et c'est bien le mobile
bien sûr mais il ya des tas d'organismes
sérieux donc le cevipof ont fait partie
y a pas de doute mais moi je vais vous
dire je fais une consultation citoyenne
sur vingt-quatre mille habitants il ya
quelques temps et justement sur la
sécurité et bien que la sécurité les
gens parlent de la tranquillité est
plutôt que de la sécurité et ça c'est
vrai il faut vraiment faire un effort
là-dessus emmanuel macron la preuve là
le le fais et je suis un de ceux qui
veulent vraiment vraiment vraiment elle
être être celui qui va aider à cette
sécurité à cette tranquillité mais les
résultats c'est 3000 personnes qui m'ont
répondu 3000 personnes qui ont répondu
et qui ne mange jamais parlé
parlons trois personnes me parle de
l'immigration
et et associe l'immigration
pour 3 personnes sur 3000 à la hauteur à
la sécurité
donc il faut revenir dans des fait
normaux il faut demander aux citoyens
absolument leur avis et le rôle des
députés le rôle de l'élu local c'est pas
faire r une pseudo consultation
mais ce faire une consultation sur des
grands thèmes comme cela et ainsi on
peut amener les personnes à pouvoir
discuter avec la politique avoir un
politique proche du terrain et avoir une
meilleure réaction et surtout une
meilleure anticipation des choses voilà
la sécurité elle est demandée mais dans
le mot sécurité c'est la tranquillité
parce que ce n'est pas normal que les
mamies qui habite au dernier étage d'un
immeuble quand elle décide on se fasse
insulter par des petits voyous ça c'est
pas normal et ça il faut le faire alors
une réaction rapide s'il vous plaît à
leur place à ce sondage
alors moi je prends beaucoup avec
beaucoup moins de désinvolture les
résultats de ce sondage
bien sûr je sais pas ce qui est entendu
dans l'étude du cevipof derrière le mot
dictature mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
les français ressemble bien 7ce et
expriment leur manque de confiance à
l'égard de leurs représentants donc il
faut que nous leur redonnons confiance
il faut qu'il croit en l'action
politique il faut qu'ils croient leurs
représentants politiques et cette
confiance elle vient aussi de l'autorité
de la force du politique et on voit bien
quel point les autorités du politique
aujourd'hui se délient dans le pays le
politique n'assume plus ses
responsabilités il assume plus ses choix
et donc il faut redonner des
perspectives aux français pour leur dire
que oui on peut avoir confiance encore
aux français les élections sont là pour
désigner leur représentant notamment les
aider les élections légistatives aussi
pour désigner les députés et les députés
sont à leurs côtés et ils peuvent encore
faire confiance
à leurs représentants encore une fois
sur la question des migrations il faut
pas se voiler la face bien sûr
qu'aujourd'hui on a une très mauvaise
politique d'immigration tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas eu de politique
d'intégration
on continue à accueillir chez nous des
gens dont nous ne sommes pas capables de
nous occuper nous leur donnons ni les
moyens et nous donnons nous mêmes amis
pas les moyens de les intégrer
convenablement fut que nous assumons
keller français de nous assurer qu'ils
sont des valeurs de la nation française
et sa cession d'habitat l'oci pour les
panthères karkadan et l'intégration
c'est réciproque
voilà merci beaucoup